This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When Harry Reeves was in middle school, he cared what his classmate started. Now all middle schoolers want to fit in with their peers, but Harry, he was next level. I was somewhat insecure as an adolescent, very unsure of my standing within the social group that I lived in and I would keep daily charts of how I was doing and who I connected with and who I did not connect with. Harry's charts did more than track who sat next to him at lunch or who joked around with him in the hallway. No this is actually more embarrassing than that.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。当哈里·里夫斯上初中时，他很在意同班同学对他的看法。现在，所有初中生都想融入同龄人群体，但哈里却达到了夸张的程度。我在青春期时多少有点不自信，对自己在所处社交圈中的地位非常不确定，我会每天记录自己表现如何、和谁建立了联系、又和谁没有建立联系。哈里的图表不仅仅是记录谁午饭时坐在他旁边，或者谁在走廊里跟他开玩笑。不，这实际上比那还要尴尬。
These were actually graphs where I would rate on a 10-point scale how I had done with various people on that day. So if I thought that a certain person had really liked me on that day, you know, they would get a nine. And if I thought I'd really come across as an idiot with another person, that might be a two or a three. and I would have these charts over time where the lines would go up and down. It was a painful way to go through middle school but it did come with an upside. Years later Harry learned there were people who
这些其实是图表，我会用10分制来给自己那天和不同人相处的情况打分。所以，如果我觉得某个人那天真的很喜欢我，你知道的，他们会得9分。而如果我觉得自己在另一个人面前表现得像个傻瓜，那可能就是2分或3分。我会一直保留这些图表，上面的线条会上下波动。对初中的经历来说，这是一种痛苦的方式，但它确实也有好的一面。多年后，哈里得知有人
kept such charts professionally. I discovered oh oh my god, there are people who actually make a life of studying this stuff. And it just instantly grabbed me because it was something that I'd always been doing. Harry went on to become a social psychologist, and he discovered that if you keep meticulous charts, if you track the ups and downs of relationships like an insecure middle schooler, you can actually discover really interesting things about the air-bend flow of human relationships. This week on Hidden Brain, we conclude our relationships 2.0 series with a look at the secret ingredient that makes some relationships thrive and others falter. Many of us know what it's like to meet a soulmate or kindred spirit at work. We know what it feels like to be inspired by a politician or a business leader.
把这种图表当作职业来做。我发现，哦，天哪，真的有人以研究这东西为生。它立刻吸引了我，因为这正是我一直在做的事情。后来，哈里成为了一名社会心理学家，他发现如果你做详细的图表，如果你像一个缺乏安全感的中学生那样追踪人际关系的起伏，你其实可以发现关于人类关系流动状态的非常有趣的事情。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们以探讨使某些关系蓬勃发展而另一些关系走向衰败的秘密成分，来结束我们的“关系2.0”系列节目。我们许多人都知道在工作中遇到灵魂伴侣或志同道合者的感觉。我们知道被政治家或商业领袖激励是什么感觉。
But what exactly prompts us to feel this deep connection with some people, but not with others? Is it having a shared goal, the intangibles of chemistry? Or does it have to do with temperament and personality? It turns out that beneath the feeling of being close to someone is a powerful psychological mechanism. At the University of Rochester, psychologist Harry Reese has studied this core ingredient of successful relationships.
但究竟是什么促使我们对某些人产生这种深厚的联系，而对其他人却没有呢？是因为有共同的目标，还是化学反应中看不摸不着的因素？或者这与气质和性格有关？事实证明，在与某人产生亲密感的感觉背后，是一个强大的心理机制。在罗切斯特大学，心理学家哈里·里夫斯研究了这种成功人际关系的核心要素。
Harry Reese, welcome to Hidden Brain. Glad to be here. I want to start by spending some time talking about a relationship in your own life, Harry. I think it speaks to some of the research insights you've developed over the years. I understand you grew up in a very tight-knit community. You got married very young to a woman who was also from that same community. What was that relationship like when you first got married? We grew up in a German Jewish community in the upper parts of Manhattan.
哈里·里夫斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。我想先花点时间谈谈你生活中的一段关系，哈里。我认为这说明了你这些年来发展出的一些研究见解。据我了解，你是在一个非常紧密团结的社区中长大的。你很年轻就结婚了，妻子也来自同一个社区。你们刚结婚时的那段关系是怎样的？我们在曼哈顿上城的一个德裔犹太人社区长大了。
And the community was very insular, it was very warm and connected. But there was also a sense that you would stay in that community when you got older, when you got married, and began to raise children on your own. And so I had the expectation that I would find a partner in that group, and in fact I did. I met my first wife when I was 19. She came from the same social community that I came from and we started dating largely because it was expected that you would start dating
而且这个社区非常封闭，非常温暖且紧密相连。但同时也有这样一种观念：当你长大、结婚并开始独自抚养孩子时，你会留在那个社区里。因此，我期望能在那个群体中找到一个伴侣，事实上我也做到了。我19岁时遇到了我的第一任妻子。她来自和我相同的社会社区，我们开始约会很大程度上是因为人们期望你在
at that age, all of my friends were doing it, all of my cousins were doing it and so I did it. And at the age of 21, we decided to get married. It was literally the exact day I graduated from college. Wow. That was the age in which all of our parents had gotten married in the old country. So that was what was expected.
那个年龄开始约会，我所有的朋友都在这样做，我所有的表亲都在这样做，所以我也这样做了。在21岁时，我们决定结婚。那 literalmente 刚好是我大学毕业的那一天。哇。那是我们所有人的父母在老家结婚的年龄。所以这就是人们所期望的。
At a certain point in your early adulthood, I think this was around the time you were in graduate school, you got involved in what were known at the time as encounter groups or encounter sessions. For people who aren't familiar with that term today, can you describe what they were, Harry? Yes. Encounter groups were very popular in the late 1960s and 1970s. They were laboratories in which people could be completely open and honest, talk about what they authentically
在你成年早期的某个时候，我想这大约是你读研究生的时候，你参与了当时被称为“相遇小组”或“相遇疗程”的活动。对于今天不太熟悉这个词的人来说，你能描述一下它们是什么吗，哈里？可以。相遇小组在20世纪60年代末和70年代非常流行。它们就像是实验室，人们可以在其中完全开放和诚实，谈论他们真正
felt, what their goals and needs were, and get honest feedback from other people about how they were coming across to them, because there's so much of our natural social interaction that involves being polite, not really talking about what you're thinking and feeling, and the ground rules of these encounter groups were to be open and honest in everything that you said and did. And did you say things in this group that you hadn't said before? Did you reveal parts of yourself that you hadn't revealed to other people in your family growing up, what your wife?
的感受、他们的目标和需求是什么，并从其他人那里得到诚实的反馈，了解自己在别人眼中是怎样的。因为我们许多的自然社交互动都涉及保持礼貌，并不真正谈论你的想法和感受，而这些相遇小组的基本规则就是在你所说和所做的一切中保持开放和诚实。你在小组里说过以前没说过的话吗？你是否透露了自己成长过程中没有向家人、甚至妻子透露过的一面？
Yes, I began to talk about how I saw my life, how I saw the community I came from, but also where I wanted to go with my life, what I wanted to accomplish professionally, but also personally, and because I was in graduate school at NYU at the time, which was in Greenwich Village, which of course was a very lively, contemporary culture at the time, which was in Greenwich Village, which of course was a very lively, contemporary culture at the time, and was beginning to experience the idea that the world I grew up in was
是的，我开始谈论我是如何看待我的生活、如何看待我出身的社区，以及我希望把生活带向何方，我想在职业上以及个人层面上取得什么成就。因为我当时在纽约大学读研究生，那里在格林威治村，当然那是一个非常充满活力、当代的文化氛围，并且开始萌生出这样一个想法：我长大的世界
not the world that I wanted to live my life in, but this was not something that I felt that I could talk about with my family or for that matter with my wife. And I began to talk about it in the context of the group and literally was blown away by the feedback that I got from other people. So you were having these sessions in these encounter groups and learning perhaps parts of yourself, learning things about yourself that you hadn't known before. Were you able to bring this back to your marriage? Were you able to talk with your wife about what was going on? Did you have conversations about it? And I'm wondering if so, what they were like?
并不是我想在其中度过余生的世界，但我觉得无法与家人或妻子谈论这件事。我开始在小组的背景下谈论它，并确实被其他人给我的反馈震撼了。所以你在这些相遇小组中进行这些对话，也许了解了自我的某些部分，了解了以前不知道的关于自己的事情。你能把这些带回到你的婚姻中吗？你能和妻子谈论发生了什么吗？你们有过这方面的对话吗？如果是的话，我想知道它们是怎样的？
Well, that was the problem. When I would begin to talk about these things, there was no recognition by my wife at all about what I was talking about. This was very contrary to what she knew about, what she had experienced, and there was just no connection there at all. And so our relationship really became a very distant relationship. It was not hostile. She was not mean about it in any way. She simply couldn't connect with it. And in a very real sense I was moving
嗯，这就是问题所在。当我开始谈论这些事情时，我的妻子对我在谈论什么完全没有共鸣。这与她所了解的、她所经历的截然相反，根本无法产生共鸣。所以我们的关系真的变成了一种非常疏离的关系。并不是充满敌意。她在这方面一点也不刻薄。她只是无法与之产生共鸣。从非常现实的意义上讲，我在朝着
in a different direction and that was a direction that she couldn't come along. So there's obviously some tension here between the kind of person you were, the encounter groups, you felt like in some ways this was the authentic Harry, in some ways you couldn't be that authentic person in your marriage. What effect did this have on your marriage, Harry? Well, it basically ended it. Of course, it took a year or a year and a half for that to actually happen. But essentially, I began to experience my outside life as far more rewarding and far more meaningful than the life that I had with my wife.
不同的方向前进，而那个方向是她无法随同的。所以这里显然存在一些张力，介于你当时的为人、那些相遇小组之间——你觉得在某种程度上这就是真实的哈里，但在某种程度上你又无法在婚姻中做那个真实的自己。这对你的婚姻产生了什么影响，哈里？嗯，它基本上终结了婚姻。当然，这花了一年或一年半的时间才真正发生。但本质上，我开始觉得我的外部生活远比我和妻子在一起的生活更有回报、更有意义。
And so we began to spend less time together, our time together would be more structure on formalities rather than the kind of intimacies that should go on in a marriage. The story that you're telling about your marriage is I think really revealing because it also matches what your research has been finding over the last several years. What is the relationship between the experience of being understood in an intimate relationship? And likelihood of success or failure of that relationship? Understanding is one of the most important things that we want in our close relationships. This is actually true beyond the realm of close relationships,
因此我们开始减少在一起的时间，我们在一起的时间更多地建立在形式化的结构上，而不是婚姻中应该有的那种亲密感。你讲述的关于你婚姻的故事我认为非常具有启发性，因为它也符合你过去几年来的研究发现。在亲密关系中，被理解的体验与什么有关？该关系的成功或失败的可能性又如何？被理解是我们希望在亲密关系中获得的最重要的东西之一。这实际上不仅适用于亲密关系领域，
but especially in our most intimate relationships, marriages, our friendships, our connections with our siblings, and the rest of our family. One of the most powerful things that we want is for there to be real understanding in those relationships, that the people on the other side know who we are and are caring and validating and accepting of that person. It's interesting I think when most people think of intimate relationships, they think about things
而且尤其适用于我们最亲密的交往、婚姻、友谊、与兄弟姐妹以及其余家人的联系。我们最强烈的愿望之一，就是这些关系中存在真正的理解，另一方的人了解我们是谁，并且对这个人充满关怀、认可和接纳。我认为有趣的是，当大多数人想到亲密关系时，他们会想到诸如
like love or you know appreciation or stability, but of course the moment you say this, it makes intuitive sense to me that one thing to be understood is absolutely core to intimate relationships. Well, I think the important point is that things like love and trust and caring simply don't work if there isn't understanding. If your understanding of me is different than how I understand myself, then when you tell me how much you love me, you're telling me that you love somebody different than me. And if I tell you how much I appreciate you, but in fact, I'm appreciating you for the things that you're not, you don't think are the most important things about yourself. Some of my feedback will now start to sound
爱、或者说欣赏或稳定之类的东西，但当然，你一说出这个，我就直觉地认为，被理解绝对是亲密关系的核心。嗯，我认为重点在于，诸如爱、信任和关怀之类的东西，如果没有理解是根本行不通的。如果你对我的理解与我对自己的理解不同，那么当你告诉我你有多爱我时，你是在告诉我你爱的是一个不同于我的人。如果我告诉你我多么感激你，但事实上，我感激的却是那些你并不认为自己身上最重要的部分。我的一些反馈现在开始听起来
inauthentic to you. And in fact, we have done research where we did exactly that. And a very interesting thing happens. People smile, they say they're happy to get the feedback, and then they want to get out of there as fast as possible in case the other person finds out how false the impression was. So it feels inauthentic and very unrewarding. It'll suppose you got a nice big raise at work from your boss and they said they're giving you the raise because of something that isn't true about you. You know
对你来说很不真实。事实上，我们做过正是这种事的实验。然后发生了一件非常有趣的事情。人们微笑着，说他们很高兴得到反馈，然后他们想以最快的速度离开那里，以防对方发现这种印象是多么虚假。所以感觉很不真实，也毫无回报。假设你在工作中从老板那里得到了一大笔加薪，而他们说给你加薪是因为一个关于你不真实的事情。你知道
think about how uncomfortable that would feel. Yeah, it makes you feel like an imposter almost. Exactly. The moment I heard about Harry's work, I started to see its applications Exactly. The moment I heard about Harry's work, I started to see its applications everywhere. Think about the perennial conflict between parents and children. So much of it can be traced to the feeling many kids have that their parents just don't get them. Take the opening scene of the movie, Lady Bird,
想想看，那会有多不舒服。是的，这让你感觉自己简直像个冒名顶替者。一点没错。我一听到哈里的工作，就开始看到它的应用。一点没错。我一听到哈里的工作，就开始看到它的应用到处都是。想想父母和孩子之间永恒的冲突。其中很大一部分可以追溯到许多孩子的一种感觉：他们的父母根本不理解他们。以电影《伯德小姐》的开场为例，
a teenager and her mom are driving back from a college tour and they start to squabble. I wish I could live through something. Aren't you? Nope. The only exciting thing about 2002 is that it's a palindrome. Okay fine, well yours is the worst life of all so you win. Oh so now you're mad. No, it's just you I wanted to listen to you
一个十几岁的女孩和她的妈妈正从大学考察之旅中开车回来，然后他们开始争吵。我希望我能经历点什么。你不是吗？没有。2002年唯一令人兴奋的事是它是个回文。好吧，好吧，反正你的生活是最糟糕的，所以你赢了。哦，所以你现在生气了。不，只是你，我想听听你的
Have a great. I'm sorry. I'm not perfect. No one's asking you to be perfect. Just consider it would do I don't even want to go to school in this state anyway. I hate California Obviously, this is a comedy but the teenagers fury at being misunderstood is palpable I want to go where culture is like you are I recently not Connecticut or new hamster where I'm in the world. I research here. Or at least Connecticut or New Hampshire where writers live in the woods. Get into those schools anyway. Mom, can't even pass your driver's test.
度过美好的一天。对不起。我并不完美。没人要求你完美。只是想想，我甚至不想在这个州的学校上学。我讨厌加州。显然，这是一部喜剧，但青少年被误解时的愤怒是显而易见的。我想去文化氛围浓厚的地方，比如……我最近……不是康涅狄格州或新罕布什尔州，我在世界上的什么地方。我的研究在这儿。或者至少是康涅狄格州或新罕布什尔州，那里有作家住在树林里。反正你也进不了那些学校。妈，你连驾照都考不过。
It's a very common feeling for adolescents and for that matter, adults, to feel like their parents don't understand them. And sometimes that comes from the fact that, you know that we grow, we change. Often we move away from our families and become things that our families don't necessarily have an appreciation of. I want to talk a little bit about the implications of your work, not in the context of intimate relationships, but in the context of professional relationships. You said a second ago that wanting to be understood is core to intimate relationships,
对于青少年以及成年人来说，觉得父母不理解自己是一种非常普遍的感受。有时这源于这样一个事实：你知道我们成长了，我们改变了。通常我们离开家庭，变成了家庭不一定能欣赏的样子。我想稍微谈谈你的研究成果的启示，不是在亲密关系的背景下，而是在职业关系的背景下。你刚才说，渴望被理解是亲密关系的核心，
but I have the sense that it also plays a role in professional relationships. Can you talk about that? Can you talk about the importance, for example, as an academic for your fellow peers, not just to think that you're a good research or a smart person, but to truly understand the insights that you have developed over the years?
但我有种感觉，它在职业关系中也发挥着作用。你能谈谈这个吗？例如，作为一个学者，对于你的同行来说，不仅要认为你是一个好的研究者或聪明的人，而且要真正理解你多年来发展出来的见解，这种重要性体现在哪里？
Well, sure, in the academy, it's very important that our colleagues, the people who are working with toward the common goal of doing research and educating students and each other. It's very important that they understand what we're trying to do in our work, that they get the message, not only the superficial content of it, but also the meta message that
当然，在学术界，非常重要的是我们的同事，那些为做研究、教育学生和彼此这一共同目标而共同努力的人。非常重要的是，他们理解我们试图在工作中做的事情，他们领会到了信息，不仅是其表面的内容，还有潜藏在其中的
is underneath that. It's true in medicine, when there's much research that shows that medical care works better when patients feel like their doctors are listening and really understand what their symptoms are, what their needs are, what they want done. It's common in the classroom also. Students do better when they feel like their teachers understand who they are and what their priorities are. It may be helpful to think about what happens when we don't receive that kind of understanding in professional settings. Students who think that professors don't understand them are more likely to end up feeling
元信息。医学界也是如此，大量研究表明，当患者觉得医生在倾听并且真正理解他们的症状、需求和他们想要怎样治疗时，医疗护理效果会更好。课堂上也很常见。当学生觉得老师理解他们是谁以及他们的优先事项时，他们的表现会更好。思考一下当我们在职业环境中没有得到这种理解时会发生什么，可能会有所帮助。认为教授不理解自己的学生更有可能最终感到
lackadaisical about their studies. A patient who thinks her doctor can't be bothered to listen to her might disregard otherwise excellent medical guidance. Over time, if we feel our colleagues and clients and customers don't understand what we go through every day, we become much more likely to snap. That's what happened to JetBlue Flight Attendant, Steven Slater. Like many flight attendants, he had trouble getting passengers to sit down while the plane was still taxing.
对学习缺乏热情。一个认为自己的医生懒得听她说话的患者可能会忽视原本极好的医疗指导。随着时间的推移，如果我们觉得我们的同事、客户和顾客不理解我们每天所经历的事情，我们发飙的可能性就会大得多。这就是捷蓝航空乘务员史蒂文·斯莱特（Steven Slater）的遭遇。像许多乘务员一样，他在飞机还在滑行时很难让乘客坐下。
As he argued with one woman, a piece of luggage got loose and hit him in the head. Here's what happened next, according to a Boston TV station. That's when witnesses say Slater lost it, telling off the entire plane cursing at passengers from the intercom. His profanity lace tirade ended with a quote, I've been in this business for 28 years. I've had it. That's it. Slater swung open the plane's side door and rode the evacuation shoot down to the tarmac. I asked Harry to talk about how a lack of understanding from colleagues and
正当他和一个女人争论时，一件行李松脱了，砸中了他的头部。根据波士顿一家电视台的报道，接下来发生了这样的事。目击者称，就在那时斯莱特崩溃了，他在对讲机里把整架飞机的人都数落了一遍，对乘客大爆粗口。他满嘴脏话的咆哮以这样一句话结束：“我在这一行干了28年了。我受够了。就这样。”斯莱特猛地推开飞机的侧门，顺着逃生滑梯滑到了停机坪上。我请哈里谈谈同事和
customers can produce burnout. People feeling misunderstood is something that is growing by leaps and bounds in the world we live in now. With all the stresses and tensions that we have, there's more and more of a need to get connected with other people and part of that connection involves the sense of really understanding where people are coming from. In the old world, most of the people that you dealt with were people from your community, people who had lives that were relatively similar to yours who lived with the same context
客户缺乏理解是如何导致职业倦怠的。人们感到被误解在我们现在生活的世界里正以惊人的速度增长。伴随着我们所有的压力和紧张，与他人建立连接的需求越来越多，而这种连接的一部分就包括真正理解他人背景的感受。在旧世界里，你打交道的大多数人都是你社区里的人，是那些生活与你相对相似、生活在
as you lived with. And it was easy enough to understand them because everything that they were facing was the same as what you were facing. But now we're so much more mobile and we're so much more connected, we're coming across people who have different backgrounds, different goals, different priorities, indeed they may be living on opposite sides of the planet. So the context is so so much different and it's so much harder to establish that core base of understanding.
与你相同背景下的人。理解他们相当容易，因为他们所面对的一切都和你所面对的一样。但现在我们的流动性大得多，连接也紧密得多，我们会遇到背景不同、目标不同、优先级不同的人，他们甚至可能生活在地球的另一端。因此，背景差异太大了，建立那种核心的理解基础要困难得多。
Why do you think it is that being understood is so important to human beings Harry? What is happening at a psychological level that makes this so important? Well, I think that's a very interesting question, Shankar. I think one of the reasons for that is that when you feel understood it's much easier to connect with another person, it means you don't need to explain yourself repeatedly. It gives you a greater sense of coherence that the world is predictable and sensible and that you can move in it freely without having to worry about how you're coming across. Am I being likable? Am I being smart? Am I being effective in that situation? I'm wondering if part of this also is that,
哈里，你认为为什么被人理解对人类如此重要？在心理层面发生了什么，使得这如此重要？嗯，我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，尚卡尔。我认为其中一个原因是，当你感到被理解时，与他人建立连接要容易得多，这意味着你不需要重复解释自己。它赋予你更高的一致性感觉，让你觉得世界是可预测和合情合理的，你可以自由地在其中穿行，而不必担心自己给别人的印象如何。我是不是很招人喜欢？我是不是很聪明？在这种情况下我是不是很有效率？我想知道其中一部分原因是否也是，
if I feel like you like me for who I am, I feel a greater liberty to actually be myself, to be authentic. Well, I feel a greater liberty to be authentic, but I also don't need to worry about rejection. We're primed by evolution to be very concerned about being accepted by our group. And we all have a very strong need to belong.
如果我觉得你因为我是谁而喜欢我，我会感到更大的自由去真正做我自己，去表现得真实。嗯，我确实感到有更大的自由去表现得真实，但我也无需担心遭到拒绝。我们在进化上就已经做好了准备，非常关注是否被我们的群体所接受。我们所有人都有着非常强烈的归属需求。
And if I'm understood, then I don't have to worry about my true self coming out and getting kicked out by the group. Whereas if I feel like the group really doesn't know me, then I'm constantly having to monitor and protect my status. Harry Rees and a number of researchers have tried to understand a paradox. If wanting to be understood is so important to our relationships and our well-being, why do so many of us regularly keep our true selves hidden? That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. A desire to be understood, to be seen for who we are, is a powerful driver of successful relationships between parents and children,
如果我被理解了，那么我就不必担心我真实的自我暴露出来而被群体踢出去。而如果我觉得群体根本不了解我，那么我就不得不时刻监控和保护我的地位。哈里·里夫斯和许多研究人员一直试图理解一个悖论：如果渴望被理解对我们的关系和幸福如此重要，为什么我们当中有那么多人经常把真实的自我隐藏起来？我们休息一下回来。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。渴望被理解、渴望因为我们本来面目而被看到，是父母与孩子之间、
between romantic partners and between colleagues. Knowing that is the easy part. Unfortunately, there are barriers that get in the way of actually reaching such understanding. Paradoxically, one major barrier can be our own desire to be understood. After Harry's first marriage ended, he remarried. He and his wife, Eleanor, both psychologists and they've been married for more than 30 years. Despite the longevity of their relationship, there are still moments when things can suddenly unravel over a trivial issue, like buying a new couch for that TV room. We have a relatively small TV room,
浪漫伴侣之间以及同事之间成功关系的强大推动力。了解这一点是容易的部分。不幸的是，有一些障碍阻碍了实际达成这种理解。矛盾的是，一个主要障碍可能正是我们自己对被理解的渴望。哈里的第一段婚姻结束后，他再婚了。他和妻子埃莉诺都是心理学家，他们已经结婚30多年了。尽管他们的关系很长久，但有时仍然会有这样的时刻：因为一些琐碎的事情，比如为电视房买一张新沙发，事情突然就谈崩了。我们的电视房相对较小，
and we had a couch in there that was comfortable for two people to sit on, but not comfortable for two people to recline on. And my wife wanted us to get a new couch that would allow us both to recline comfortably on it, whereas I wanted to keep this couch because it was perfectly comfortable for me. I'm a large person. And this is one of the few couches that I've sat on that worked perfectly for me. I'm a large person. And this is one of the few couches that I've sat on
里面有一张沙发，两个人坐着很舒服，但两个人躺着并不舒服。我妻子想让我们买一张新沙发，好让我们俩都能在上面舒服地躺着，而我想保留这张沙发，因为它对我来说绝对舒适。我个子很大。这是我坐过的少数几张对我来说完美适用的沙发之一。我个子很大。这是我坐过的少数几张对我来说完美适用的沙发之一。
that worked perfectly for me. And so this seems like a very, you know, we both have reasonable positions, of course. And so of course, what you did was you sat down reasonably and discussed the pros and cons of getting a new couch, right? Well, no, not exactly. You know, there's a truism that psychologists like to talk about is, who are the worst patients
所以这似乎是一个非常……你知道的，我们俩的立场当然都是合理的。所以，当然，你所做的就是心平气和地坐下来，讨论买新沙发的利弊，对吧？嗯，不，不完全是。你知道，心理学家喜欢讨论的一个真理是：谁是心理治疗中最糟糕的病人？
for psychotherapy? And the answer is a couple of psychologists. And the reason for that is that each knows exactly what's wrong with the other person, and if the other person would only fix it, everything would be fine. And in a sense, that's how our initial conversations about the couch began. We would discuss what we liked or didn't like about the couch, and each of us would complete the other person's sentences, because we were absolutely certain that we understood what was going on in the other ones' mind. The key part of that that was so unhelpful is the not allowing the perspectives to be talked about, to allow them to come out in a marriage and for that matter in any kind of relationship, to resolve a conflict involves putting aside one's presumptions about what the other person is thinking and
答案是一对心理学家。原因在于，每个人都确切地知道对方出了什么问题，如果对方只是把它修好，一切都会好起来的。从某种意义上说，我们最初关于沙发的对话就是这样开始的。我们会讨论我们喜欢或不喜欢沙发的什么地方，而且我们每个人都会帮对方把话说完，因为我们绝对确凿地认为我们理解了对方脑海中在想什么。其中最没有帮助的关键一点，就是不允许把各自的观点说出来，不允许它们在婚姻中——甚至在任何类型的关系中——浮出水面。解决冲突需要抛弃对对方所思所想的先入为主的假设，
feeling, even if those presumptions might be right, and instead really listening to what the other person is saying, and then making it clear that one really is listening, and that became the solution to the couch problem. When we stopped interrupting each other and stopped talking over each other, and very clearly stated what each of us wanted to happen. We actually came to a very good agreement about it, which was that we searched for a couch that had the length that my wife wanted and that had the support features that I wanted. And it took a little bit of doing, but we found one,
即使这些假设可能是对的，而是真正去倾听对方在说什么，然后明确表示自己确实在听，而这成为了解决沙发问题的解决方案。当我们停止互相打断、停止抢话，并且非常清楚地陈述我们各自希望发生的事情时，我们实际上达成了一个非常好的协议，那就是我们寻找了一张既有我妻子想要的长度、又有我想要的支撑功能的沙发。这花了一点工夫，但我们找到了，
and it's coming next week. And of course, this is a trivial example. It obviously resolved in a perfectly happy manner, but you can see how the same dynamics play out in all kinds of other situations with far less, you know, agreeable outcomes, where two parties are in conflict with one another. Each of them feels like the other is not, not only not understanding them,
下周就送货。当然，这是一个微不足道的例子。它显然以非常愉快的方式解决了，但你可以看到，同样的动态在各种其他情况中是如何上演的，而结果却远没有那么令人愉快，其中两方处于冲突之中。他们每个人都觉得对方不仅不理解自己，
but not making any attempt to understand them. Each of them is trying to get that position out, unable to hear what the other person is saying. And this combination of wanting to be understood and not being able to offer understanding to the other person ends up being really toxic. Yes, that's absolutely correct. We are not perfectly articulate human beings. When we communicate, we don't necessarily measure every word perfectly. We use linguistic styles that may not be 100% compatible
而且没有做出任何试图理解他们的尝试。他们每个人都在试图表达自己的立场，却无法听到对方在说些什么。这种渴望被理解却又无法向对方提供理解的结合，最终变得极具毒性。是的，完全正确。我们并不是完美表达自我的真正人类。当我们沟通时，我们不一定完美地权衡每一个字。我们使用的语言风格可能无法与对方100%兼容。
with the other person. We make assumptions in our heads about, you know, what we're thinking and feeling that don't always come across. And so the process of communication is a very imperfect one. And the more imperfect it is, the more difficult it is to develop a true sense of understanding. So, besides some of the conflicts that we've been talking about in the course of interpersonal relationships, you and others have also identified a host of psychological barriers
我们在脑海中对我们的想法和感受做出的假设并不总能准确传达。因此，沟通的过程是一个非常不完美的过程。它越是不完美，发展出真正的理解感就越困难。所以，除了我们在人际关系中一直在谈论的一些冲突之外，你和其他人还确定了许多心理障碍，
that cause people in some ways to hide themselves from others but also cause them not to see others clearly. And I want to look at some of these in detail. The research at Tom Gillovich once ran a study where volunteers were videotaped sampling a variety of beverages and one of these contained a disgusting vinegar, brine solution. The volunteers were told to conceal their feelings of disgust and then ask to guess whether others would notice that they were disgusted.
这些障碍在某种程度上导致人们向他人隐藏自己，但也导致他们无法清晰地看到他人。我想详细探讨其中一些。汤姆·吉洛维奇（Tom Gilovich）的研究曾进行过一项研究：志愿者们被录像品尝各种饮料，其中一种含有令人作呕的醋盐水溶液。志愿者被告知要隐藏他们厌恶的feelings，然后被问及是否认为别人会注意到他们感到厌恶。
Can you tell me what happened and what bearing this has to our conversation about being understood? Well, we often assume that other people can see what we're feeling even when we don't actually express those feelings. So often I might be angry but not do a terribly good job of explaining that, and I would assume that everyone knows that I'm angry without necessarily that coming across. And of course, that's exactly what happened in the study. The volunteers, in fact, thought that their feelings of disgust would be obvious to other people, but they were not. And
你能告诉我发生了什么吗？这与我们关于被理解的对话有什么关系？嗯，我们经常假设其他人能看到我们的感受，即使我们并没有真正表达这些感受。所以很多时候我可能会生气，但并没有把这种生气解释得很好，我会以为每个人都知道我在生气，而无需这种情绪真正传达出去。当然，这正是研究中发生的情况。事实上，志愿者们认为他们厌恶的感受对其他人来说应该是显而易见的，但事实并非如此。
Tom Gillovich and his colleagues talked about the illusion of transparency that we believe that What we feel on the inside is transparent to those on the outside? Right, you know some of us are better at being transparent than others but one of the biggest misconceptions People have about marriage especially before they go into marriage, is that their partner will always know what they're thinking and feeling. And this is a very, very destructive expectation. So, sometimes, of course, the problem is not that we believe that we are transparent,
汤姆·吉洛维奇和他的同事们谈到了透明度错觉，我们认为我们在内心感受到的东西对外界来说是透明的。没错，你知道，我们中的一些人比其他人更善于保持透明，但人们对婚姻最大的误解之一，特别是在他们步入婚姻之前，就是认为他们的伴侣会永远知道他们在想什么和感受到什么。这是一个非常非常具有破坏性的期望。所以，有时问题当然不是我们认为自己是透明的，
sometimes we're actively trying to hide elements of ourselves from others. When you're just getting to know someone, for example, it doesn't seem like a good time to show all of your cards. Yes, and of course there are many situations in which it's appropriate not to show all of your cards, but more importantly, I think there are many situations in which people try not to show all their cards when that is actually problematic. In dating situations, for example, we're clearly putting our best foot forward in the early stages and even much later in the relationship. People often have what we call hidden selves.
有时我们是在积极试图向他人隐藏自己的某些元素。例如，当你刚刚开始了解某人时，这似乎并不是亮出你所有底牌的好时机。是的，当然在许多情况下，不亮出你所有的底牌是合适的，但更重要的是，我认为在许多情况下，当这实际上成问题时，人们却试图不亮出所有的底牌。例如，在约会中，我们在早期阶段显然会展现出自己最好的一面，甚至在关系后面的阶段也是如此。人们经常拥有我们所谓的隐藏自我。
We have aspects of ourselves that we're really quite afraid that other people will find out because it's embarrassing, because it will embarrassing, because it will make us vulnerable, because we fear that it might make our partners second guess their interest in us. So you and others have found that when people experience a sense of being understood, they
我们有自己的一面，我们真的很害怕被别人发现，因为这令人尴尬，因为这会令人尴尬，因为这会让我们变得脆弱，因为我们担心这可能会让我们的伴侣重新考虑他们对我们的兴趣。所以你和其他人发现，当人们体验到被理解的感觉时，他们
are drawn closer to those people. So in other words, being understood prompts people to feel closer to the people who understand them. But in tenuous relationships, there's something of a vicious cycle. The more insecure we feel, the more hesitant we become about sharing elements of ourselves that might be judged harshly by others. And of course, the less we share, the less close we feel to others. So it seems to me that some of these dynamics can produce a vicious cycle. Yes, you're talking about the idea of self-fulfilling prophecy and the irony there is that in the very situation you described, people will often be right there partner for not understanding them and yet they've been deliberately hiding aspects of themselves.
会被吸引得更接近那些人。换句话说，被理解促使人们与理解他们的人感觉更亲近。但在脆弱的关系中，存在着某种恶性循环。我们感到越没有安全感，我们就越犹豫是否要分享那些可能被别人严厉评判的自我元素。当然，我们分享得越少，我们对别人的亲密感就越少。在我看来，其中一些动态会产生恶性循环。是的，你正在谈论的是自证预言的概念，而其中的讽刺之处在于，在你所描述的这种情况下，人们经常会责怪他们的伴侣不理解他们，然而他们自己却一直在刻意隐藏自己的某些方面。
So we've looked at several ways in which we might hide important parts of ourselves from others, but let's flip the script for a second. It turns out that we also regularly fail to take the time to extend understanding to others. And to go back to your story about the couch, part of the problem was that you were not slowing down enough to hear your wife's perspective because you were so anxious to get out your own. Yes. Well, many times we are much more interested in expressing our point of view than in listening to the other person's point of view. This is one of the great conversation skills that people sometimes need to learn. Instead of
我们已经探讨了我们可能向他人隐藏自己重要部分的几种方式，但让我们换个角度思考一下。事实证明，我们也经常没有花时间去向他人延伸理解。回到你关于沙发的例子，部分问题在于你没有放慢脚步去聆听你妻子的观点，因为你太急于表达你自己的观点了。是的。嗯，很多时候，我们对表达自己的观点比对倾听对方的观点要感兴趣得多。这是人们有时需要学习的伟大的谈话技巧之一。人们不会
listening, people will be thinking about what's the next thing I'm going to say. And when you do that, it's that much harder to understand what the other person is actually talking about. We really have to learn how to focus our attention on the other person rather than ourselves. I'm wondering if gender dynamics play a role here as well. It seems to me at least, you know, from anecdotal experience that women are more forthcoming than men are in sort of revealing elements of themselves and wanting to be understood and seeking to understand. Is that a stereotype or do you think there's some truth in it?
倾听，而是在思考我接下来要说的是什么。当你这样做时，要理解对方真正在谈论什么就难得多了。我们真的必须学会如何将注意力集中在对方身上，而不是我们自己身上。我想知道性别动态在这里是否也起作用。在我看来，至少根据经验来看，女性比男性更愿意坦白，在某种程度上透露自己的元素，渴望被理解并寻求理解。这是一种刻板印象，还是你认为其中有一些真相？
Well, what there is truth in, I think, is the idea that women are better at doing the understanding. Women are better at paying attention to what other other person is saying and expressing that in a way that comes across to the other person. Women also do tend to be somewhat more emotionally open. We've done a lot of research on that gender difference and what's interesting about it is that women tend to be relatively more open, regardless of the gender of the person that they're talking to.
嗯，我认为有真实成分的是这种想法：女性更擅长去理解。女性更擅长关注另一个人在说什么，并以一种能让对方感同身受的方式表达出来。女性也往往在情感上更加开放。我们对这种性别差异做了很多研究，有趣的是，无论她们交谈的对象性别如何，女性往往相对更开放。
But men tend to be open primarily with women. In other words, men when they're interacting with other men are less likely to be emotionally open. And that often interferes with men's developing close friendships, particularly later in life. You have an interesting story about something you overheard at the gym where a couple of men were having a heart to heart, or at least one of them was having a heart to heart.
但男性的开放主要针对女性。换句话说，男性在与其他男性互动时，不太可能在情感上开放。这往往会阻碍男性建立亲密的友谊，特别是在晚年的时候。你有一个有趣的故事，关于你在健身房无意中听到的一件事，有几个男人在那里推心置腹，或者至少其中一个人在推心置腹。
Yes, I was at my gym and there were two young men standing there and one of them said, you know, how are you doing to the other? And the other said, oh, it's just terrible. My wife left me, I lost my job, and I had an auto accident. And the other man said, wow, you know, it's really important to get your feelings out. Why don't you tell me about it? And my ears perked up.
是的，我在健身房里，有两个年轻人在那里站着，其中一个对另一个说：“你最近怎么样？”另一个说：“哦，太糟糕了。我妻子离开了我，我失业了，我还出了车祸。”另一个男人说：“哇，你知道的，把你的感受发泄出来真的很重要。你为什么不跟我讲讲呢？”我的耳朵竖起来了。
I thought, wow, this is exactly what we're talking about. And then he said, and I've got a minute, so go ahead. I feel there are also times, Harry, when we may actively not want to understand someone else. If you sense that a friend or a colleague or a romantic partner thinks poorly of you, it almost might be less painful if you engaged in some willful blindness. Can you talk about this as being one of the barriers to actually understanding other people? Yes, we talk about this as when the head protects the heart. And the simple idea here is that there are many things that other people might be thinking
我想，哇，这正是我们在谈论的。然后他说：“我还有一分钟时间，说吧。”我觉得有时候，哈里，我们可能也会积极地不想去理解别人。如果你觉得一个朋友、同事或浪漫伴侣对你的看法很差，如果你进行某种刻意的盲目，可能痛苦会少一些。你能谈谈这作为真正理解他人的障碍之一吗？是的，我们把这称为“大脑保护心脏”的时候。这里的简单想法是，别人可能会有许多关于我们的想法
about us that we don't want to know about. For example, early in a dating relationship, we may not want to really know what the other person thinks of ourselves. It might be unpleasant. It might not be what we want to hear. In a conversation with a teacher or a work supervisor, we may not want to really know what the other person thinks of what we're doing because it may not be entirely complimentary to ourselves. And so often we have blinders. Now of course, when you take this to an extreme, it's quite dysfunctional, but at relatively low levels,
是我们不想知道的。例如，在约会关系的早期，我们可能真的不想知道对方对我们自己的看法。那可能是令人不快的。可能不是我们想听到的。在与老师或工作主管的对话中，我们可能真的不想知道对方对我们所做事情的看法，因为这可能对我们并非完全是赞美的。所以我们经常戴着眼罩。当然，当你把这一点推向极端时，它是相当功能失调的，但在相对较低的水平上，
this may be highly functional. at relatively low levels, this may be highly functional. We often do a getting acquainted exercise with students where we ask students what superpower they would like. And as soon as a student always says the ability to read other people's minds, and I think it's safe to say that the ability to read other people's mind is the worst thing that could happen to us. Research has once asked a couple of hundred couples to write down every evening for a couple of weeks how considered or selfish that partner had been or how supportive that had been, and then I've had them predict how that partners would behave the next day. And the researchers generally found that people believed that the way that partners had
这可能是高度功能性的。在相对较低的水平上，这可能是高度功能性的。我们经常和学生做一个结识练习，问学生他们想要什么超能力。一旦一个学生总是说能够读懂别人心思的能力，我想可以肯定地说，能够读懂别人心思的能力可能是发生在我们身上最糟糕的事情。研究曾要求几百对夫妇在几周内每天晚上写下他们的伴侣有多体贴或多自私，或者有多支持对方，然后让他们预测他们的伴侣第二天会怎么做。研究人员普遍发现，人们认为伴侣在第一天的行为表现
behaved on day one was a good predictor of how they would behave on day two. So in other words, we assume that the people who we are engaging with today, their behaviors are not going to change in the future. And of course, one of the reasons in some ways we fail to understand other people is that our impressions of who they are are rooted in the past. Well we have a strong belief that character is a major determinant of behavior. And so we assume that people are going to be consistent from one situation to another, from one day to another,
是预测他们第二天会如何表现的良好指标。换句话说，我们假设我们今天与之交往的人，他们的行为在未来是不会改变的。当然，我们在某些方面未能理解其他人的原因之一，就是我们对他们的印象植根于过去。嗯，我们坚信性格是决定行为的主要因素。因此，我们假设人们从一种情境到另一种情境、从一天到另一天都会保持一致
indeed, even from one period of life to another period of life. And what we under consider is the idea that people grow, people change, that people's situations change, and that that leads them to behave in different ways as well. So often when we're dealing with partners, when we're dealing with students, when we're dealing with co-workers, we don't account for the fact that people develop, people change in priorities, people mature, and that they behave differently over time.
事实上，甚至从人生的一个阶段到另一个阶段也是如此。我们所考虑到的是这样一种观点：人们在成长，人们在改变，人们的处境在改变，这也会导致他们以不同的方式行事。因此，通常当我们与伴侣、学生或同事相处时，我们往往忽视了这样一个事实：人们在发展，人们的优先事项在改变，人们在成熟，而且随着时间的推移，他们的行为也会有所不同。
This is especially, I think, acute when you're talking about parents and children, so the mom who thinks the adolescent son always needs help has trouble adapting to the fact that maybe the adolescent son now is 25 years old and perhaps doesn't need her help as much. One of the hardest things about parenting is that children develop and they often develop rather quickly and recognizing the skill changes or the need changes that a child goes through is often difficult for parents to keep up with. Tell me about the time your mom came to visit you when you were first in Rochester. You were 25 years old, I believe.
我认为，当你谈论父母和孩子时，这种情况尤其明显。比如，一个母亲认为青春期的儿子总是需要帮助，她就很难适应这样一个事实：也许这个青春期的儿子现在已经25岁了，可能不再那么需要她的帮助了。为人父母最难的事情之一，就是孩子在成长，而且他们往往成长得相当快。要跟上孩子所经历的技能变化或需求变化，对父母来说往往是很困难的。能跟我讲讲你刚到罗切斯特时你妈妈去看望你的那次经历吗？我记得你当时25岁。
Tell me that story, Harry. Yes, I was 25 years old. This was the first time I lived in a house of my own. My mother walked in the door and without taking her jacket off, started to clean the sink. And it was not that dirty. Did you have a conversation with her about this? I mean, you say, you know, I'm the psychologist. I know exactly what you're doing. No, I was happy to have my sink clean.
跟我讲讲那个故事吧，哈里。是的，我当时25岁。这是我第一次住进属于自己的房子。我母亲走进门，甚至没脱下夹克，就开始打扫水槽。其实那个水槽并没有那么脏。你和她谈过这件事吗？我的意思是，你会说，你知道的，我是心理学家，我完全清楚你在做什么。不，我很高兴能有人把我的水槽擦干净。
One of the things I'm taking away from all this work, Harry, is that, you know, being understood requires significant effort from two parties. So understanding tends to happen when you have an excellent communicator paired with an excellent empath. And of course, when you put it that way, it becomes much less surprising that so many of us go through life without getting the understanding that we want or without extending understanding to others. Yes, that's correct.
哈里，我从所有这些工作中汲取到的经验之一，就是你知道，要被理解需要双方的巨大努力。因此，理解往往发生在当你拥有一个优秀的沟通者和一个优秀的共情者的时候。当然，如果你这么说的话，我们中的许多人终其一生都无法得到想要的理解，或者无法向他人延伸理解，这也就变得不那么令人惊讶了。是的，确实如此。
A failure on either end of that transaction can make it go bad. Can you talk for a moment about the experience of getting this understanding given that it's rare, given that it doesn't happen always, I think many of us have a feeling of almost transcendence when we feel like we're paired with someone who truly gets us. Well, I would not quite want to go as far as you're going and saying that we don't have this kind of understanding. We certainly don't have this kind of complete understanding, but if we didn't have some
这个过程的任何一端出现故障都可能导致事情变糟。你能花点时间谈谈获得这种理解的体验吗？鉴于这种理解很罕见，鉴于它并不总是发生，我想我们许多人在觉得自己和一个真正懂我们的人在一起时，都会有一种近乎超越的感受。嗯，我可不想像你走得那么远，说我们没有这种理解。我们当然没有这种完全的理解，但如果我们没有某种
level of understanding, we would all be deflecting and bouncing off each other in many ways. So there's some level of basic understanding that is quite common in our lives. And for that to happen, we have to be reasonably open in expressing what's important to us and reasonably good listeners in paying attention to what's being said to us. When we come back, it curious twists. It turns out there is a big difference between being understood and feeling understood. Also, given the barriers we face to understanding, what skills can help us become more connected to others and allow us to understand them a little better. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
程度的理解，我们在很多方面都会相互偏转和碰撞。因此，在我们生活中，某种程度的基本理解是很常见的。要做到这一点，我们必须在表达对我们重要的事情时相当坦诚，而在倾听对我们说的话时也要做相当优秀的倾听者。当我们回来时，会有有趣的转折。事实证明，被理解和感到被理解之间存在着巨大的差异。此外，鉴于我们在理解上面临的障碍，什么技能能帮助我们与他人建立更多联系，并让我们更好地理解他们？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The desire to feel understood appears to be a core psychological need. When we have it, we are happier colleagues, warmer partners and more loyal friends. When we don't feel understood, it can corrode even our best relationships. Psychologist Harry Rves studies intermittal relationships. He's found that being understood is a pillar of successful relationships, but there are all kinds of cognitive biases that keep us from being understood and keep us from understanding others.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。渴望被理解似乎是一项核心心理需求。当我们拥有它时，我们会成为更快乐的同事、更温暖的伙伴和更忠诚的朋友。当我们不被理解时，它甚至会侵蚀我们最好的关系。心理学家哈里·里斯研究人际关系。他发现被理解是成功关系的支柱，但各种各样的认知偏差阻碍了我们被理解，也阻碍了我们理解他人。
Harry, one of the most interesting aspects of your research is that you found a difference between being understood and feeling understood. Can you explain this difference to me? Yes. Being understood refers to whether you really understand what another person is like, what their preferences are, what their character traits are, what their needs are, what their desires are, feeling understood, it's entirely within the mind of the perceiver and it's the belief that another person really understands who you are and what's important to you.
哈里，你研究中最有趣的一个方面是，你发现被理解和感到被理解之间存在着差异。你能向我解释一下这种差异吗？可以的。被理解指的是你是否真正理解另一个人的性格、他们的偏好、他们的性格特征、他们的需求、他们的欲望；而感到被理解，则完全在感知者的内心，它是一种信念，即另一个人真正理解你是谁以及什么对你重要。
And you're saying that there are sometimes cases where people may feel understood without actually being understood? Yes, there are. One of the things we've found in our work is that when people have successful relationships, they often imagine that other people understand them better than they actually do. And this is one thing that actually helps them maintain a sense of security and safety in that relationship. And you've done studies to this effect, I understand, where you show that in some ways the belief that you are understood, the feeling that you have of being understood, in fact,
你是说有时人们会觉得自己被理解，但实际上并没有被理解？是的，确实如此。我们在工作中发现的一点是，当人们拥有成功的人际关系时，他们常常会想象别人比实际情况更好地理解了他们。正是这一点，实际上帮助他们在这种关系中保持了一种安全感和保障感。我了解到，你曾就此做过研究，表明在某些情况下，你被理解的信念，你所拥有的被理解的感觉，事实上，
is a strong predictor of the success of that relationship, not necessarily the fact that people actually are understood. Yes, that's correct. Well, what we did in this work was look at the extent to which people felt understood by their close relationship partners in two different areas. One is in the area of sexual preferences and the other was in the area of humor preferences. And what we found was quite interesting and that's that when people feel very satisfied with their relationships and when they feel very similar to the people that they're relating to, they actually imagine that there's a greater level of understanding than there actually
是这段关系成功的一个强有力的预测指标，而不一定是因为人们真的被理解了。是的，确实如此。我们在研究中所做的是，考察人们在两个不同领域感受到来自亲密关系伴侣的理解程度。一个是性偏好领域，另一个是幽默偏好领域。我们发现的结果非常有趣：当人们对自己的关系感到非常满意，并且当他们觉得与自己交往的人非常相似时，他们实际上会想象存在着比实际情况更高的理解水平。
is. Now this is a good thing because that greater level of feeling understood allows them to feel more confident, more safe, more happy in the relationship. So we talk about this as a maintenance mechanism and by that we mean a way of thinking about your relationship that actually boosts the integrity and the coherence and the safety of the relationship. I'm thinking about this also in the context of politics. Politicians like Bill Clinton or Donald Trump, they're loved by their supporters in part because people feel like they understand them.
现在，这是一件好事，因为这种更高程度的被理解感让他们在关系中感到更自信、更安全、更快乐。因此，我们将其称为维持机制，我们的意思是，这是一种看待你们关系的方式，实际上它增强了关系的完整性、连贯性和安全性。我也在政治背景下思考这个问题。像比尔·克林顿或唐纳德·特朗普这样的政治家，他们深受支持者的喜爱，部分原因是因为人们觉得这些人懂他们。
Is that stretching your research too far to extend it to the realm of politics? No, I think that implication follows quite naturally. Both Bill Clinton and Donald Trump were able to communicate to other people something that made it sound like he really understood what was important to those people. And that is a major determinant of people's identification with candidates. Their willingness to go out and vote for those candidates are perhaps to even donate to them. In my state, when people lose their jobs, it's a good chance I'll know them by their names.
将你的研究延伸到政治领域，是不是有点牵强了？不，我认为这种含义是顺理成章的。比尔·克林顿和唐纳德·特朗普都能够向他人传达某些东西，听起来就像他真的理解对这些人来说什么才是重要的。这是人们对候选人产生认同感的一个主要决定因素。他们愿意出去投票给这些候选人，甚至可能向他们捐款。在我的州，当人们失业时，我很有可能会叫出他们的名字。
When the factory closes, I know the people who ran it. When the businesses go bankrupt, I know them. People that have lost their jobs, lost their livelihood, lost their health insurance. What I want you to understand is, on the campaign, I called it, the forgotten man and the forgotten woman. Well, you're not forgotten anymore, that I can tell you. Not forgotten anymore that I can tell you. Not forgotten anymore. And I think it might also be a measure of how much we are willing to forgive candidates,
当工厂倒闭时，我认识经营它的人。当企业破产时，我认识他们。那些失去了工作、失去了生计、失去了健康保险的人。我想让你们明白的是，在竞选期间，我称之为被遗忘的男人和被遗忘的女人。好吧，你们不再被遗忘了我可以告诉你们。我可以告诉你们，你们不再被遗忘了。不再被遗忘了。我想这也可能是衡量我们愿意原谅候选人的程度的一个标准，
even if they fail to deliver on promises that they have made to us, when we feel like the candidates understand us, that this leader truly gets us, this leader is perhaps even one of us. You're willing to forgive all kinds of things, even if the candidate doesn't actually deliver once he or she is in office. Yes, I think that's exactly right. I want to turn to some of the techniques that we can use to better understand other people and to be better understood by others. Psychotherapists sometimes use a technique called speaker listener technique to help couples overcome misunderstandings. Can you describe this technique to me Harry?
即使他们未能兑现对我们的承诺，当我们觉得候选人理解我们，这位领袖真正懂我们，这位领袖甚至可能是我们中的一员时。你愿意原谅各种各样的事情，即使这位候选人在上任后并没有真正兑现承诺。是的，我认为完全是这样。我想转向一些我们可以用来更好地理解他人以及被他人更好地了解的技术。心理治疗师有时会使用一种叫做“说话者-倾听者”的技术来帮助伴侣克服误解。哈里，你能给我描述一下这项技术吗？
Sure. The speaker listener technique is a very straightforward way of trying to both enforce the idea of needing to listen but also to create the sense of being listened to. So, in the speaker-listener technique, there will be a box on the table with two red lights, one in front of each partner. And the way the process works is only the partner who has the light is allowed to speak. So, the lights on, you're allowed to speak, and you can say whatever your concerns or issues are, then the light is allowed to speak. So the lights on, you're allowed to speak and you can say whatever your concerns or issues are, then the light switches and the partner's job is to repeat what you just said as they heard it. Then the first person's light comes back on and that person then has to comment on whether you got it right or how you got it wrong.
当然。“说话者-倾听者”技术是一种非常直接的方法，旨在既强调需要倾听的理念，又创造出被倾听的感觉。因此，在“说话者-倾听者”技术中，桌上会有一个盒子，上面有两盏红灯，分别在每个伴侣的前面。这个过程的运作方式是，只有拥有亮灯的伴侣才被允许发言。所以灯亮着，你就可以说话，你可以表达你的担忧或问题，然后灯就会切换，另一个伴侣的任务是按照他们听到的那样重复你刚说的话。然后第一个人的灯重新亮起，这个人接着必须评论你是否说对了或者你在哪里弄错了。
And then the other person's light comes back on and they have to amend what they said to reflect the feedback that you just gave them. So in some ways you're slowing people down to the point where each side says, not only have I had my say, I am now sure the other person has heard me in exactly the way that I want to be heard. Right, but it's more than just slowing down because lots of times people know that they have to shut up while the other person is saying the point of view, but their mind will be closed. This technique forces them to open their minds and really listen to what's being said. Uh-huh.
然后另一个人的灯重新亮起，他们必须修正自己刚才说的话，以反映你刚才给他们的反馈。所以在某些方面，你把人们的速度放慢到这样的程度：双方都说，不仅我把话说完了，我现在还确信另一个人完全按照我希望被听到和我想要的方式听到了我说话。对，但这不仅仅是放慢速度，因为很多时候人们知道在另关人员阐述观点时自己必须闭嘴，但他们的内心是封闭的。这项技术迫使他们敞开心扉，真正去倾听对方所说的话。嗯哼。
What are the salutary effects that greater understanding might bring, both in terms of our personal psychology, but also in the way we treat other people? Yes, we've done a number of studies of this where we use an experimental manipulation that will temporarily allow people to feel more understood or alternatively to feel more misunderstood. And what we find is that once we give people a sense that they've been understood, that they've been validated and responded to, they become more open-minded, they become more willing to consider opposite points of view. This is work that I did with an Israeli colleague
更大的理解可能会带来什么样有益的影响，既体现在我们的个人心理方面，也体现在我们对待其他人的方式上？是的，我们对此做过许多研究，在研究中我们使用了一种实验操纵，可以暂时让人们感到更被理解，或者相反，感到更被误解。我们发现，一旦我们让人们感觉到他们被理解了、他们的感受得到了验证和回应，他们就会变得更加思想开放，更愿意考虑相反的观点。这是我与一位以色列同事共同完成的研究
named Guy Itchakoff, and we gave people a sense of being understood, and then measured their prejudice toward some out group that they might have known. Perhaps it was an ethnic group, perhaps it was people with a different sexuality. Some group that prior to the study, they had expressed some negativity toward and we found that after feeling understood they become
名叫盖伊·伊查科夫（Guy Itchakoff），我们让人们体验到被理解的感觉，然后衡量他们对可能认识的某些外群体（out-group）的偏见。也许是一个族群，也许是具有不同性取向的人。在研究之前，他们曾对某些群体表现出一些负面情绪，而我们发现，在感到被理解之后，他们变得
less concerned with inflating their view of themselves of thinking of themselves in a more ego-enhancing way and Most importantly and most interestingly they become less prejudiced towards out groups. I'm wondering if you can tell me a little bit about some of the techniques that you employ yourself having done this work for many years after seeing the importance of actual understanding as well as communicating understanding to other people. How has this changed the way you interact with others in terms of your students, your colleagues, your partners, your friends, your family? Do you do things differently today than you did in the past?
不再那么关注膨胀对自己的看法，不再以那种更能增强自我感知的方式来看待自己，最重要也最有趣的是，他们对外部群体的偏见减少了。我想知道你能不能跟我谈谈你自己采用的一些技术，在做了多年这项工作、并看到了实际理解以及向他人传达理解的重要性之后。这如何改变了你与他人互动的方式，包括你的学生、同事、伴侣、朋友、家人？你现在的做法和过去有什么不同吗？
Oh, absolutely. One of the things I do, particularly with students, is that, you know, students will often come to you with a request for this, that, or the other thing. And often it's not a request that we can grant. And rather than just, you know, say, no, sorry, I will sort of go out of my way to make it clear that I understood what they said. I think it's a perfectly reasonable thing for them to ask for, but I just can't do it. They may feel turned down, but at least they know that I paid attention and respected where they were coming from. I want to stay with that insight for a moment,
哦，当然。我做的一件事，特别是在对待学生时，你知道，学生经常会来找你提出这个、那个或其他的请求。通常这不是我们能满足的请求。与其只是对他们说“不，很抱歉”，我不如说是会特意让他们明白我理解了他们所说的话。我认为他们的要求完全合理，只是我办不到。他们可能会觉得被拒绝了，但至少他们知道我注意倾听了，并且尊重他们的出发点。我想在这个洞察上停留一会儿，
because in some ways, I think what you're hinting at, at least, is that sometimes the pain we feel in disagreements might be less about the disagreement, and it might be more about how we feel the other person has heard us or listened to us or taken us seriously. Absolutely. There is research by one of my colleagues, Amy Gordon, where she has shown that conflicts, even when they don't get resolved, are less harmful to relationships when people feel
因为在某种程度上，我认为你至少在暗示，有时我们在分歧中感受到的痛苦可能较少关于分歧本身，而更多地关于我们觉得对方是如何听到我们、倾听我们或认真对待我们的。绝对是这样的。我的同事艾米·戈登（Amy Gordon）做过一项研究，她表明冲突即使没有得到解决，当人们觉得
like they've been heard and understood. One of the misconceptions that people have is that if you express understanding for what the other person is saying that you're somehow agreeing with their point of view, and that needn't be the case. Understanding simply means making it clear that you get the message that they communicated and that you respect it as a reasonable point of view. That doesn't mean that you have to agree with it. But it's what flagging. The reason that I think many of us fail to do this, fail to understand others or fail to have ourselves be understood. Is it actually, is it's hard? It does involve time, it involves effort, and it involves emotional effort.
自己被倾听和理解时，对关系的损害也会减小。人们的一个误解是，如果你对对方所说的话表示理解，你就是在某种程度上同意他们的观点，其实并不需要这样。理解仅仅意味着明确表示你收到了他们传达的信息，并且作为一个合理的观点尊重它。这并不意味着你必须同意它。但这是值得指出的。我认为我们中的许多人做不到这一点的原因，即未能理解他人或未能让自己被理解。是因为它实际上很难。它确实需要时间，需要努力，也需要情感上的努力。
And it also involves vulnerability. It involves being open to hearing something that you might not like. So in some ways, the act of doing this involves, you know, an element of courage, I suppose. It definitely involves courage. The courage to tell you who I really am, and the courage to listen to who you really are. Harry Rees is a psychologist at the University of Rochester.
它还涉及脆弱性。它涉及敞开心扉去听一些你可能不喜欢的话。所以在某种程度上，做这件事的行为包含着一种勇气，我想。它绝对需要勇气。向你袒露真实自我的勇气，以及倾听真实你的勇气。哈里·里斯是罗切斯特大学的心理学家。
Harry, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. My pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is the psychologist Sonia Lubamerski.
哈里，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。我的荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒公司（Hidden Brain Media）制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是心理学家索尼亚·柳博米尔斯基（Sonia Lyubomirsky）。
She was featured in our episode Where Happiness Hides. After we talked, Sonia told us about Harry Reese's research on the importance of feeling understood. Thank you Sonia for introducing us to Harry's work. If you enjoyed this episode, make sure you go back and check out our entire Relationships 2.0 series. And if you'd like us to produce more series like this one, please consider supporting our work.
她曾出现在我们的节目《幸福隐藏在哪里》（Where Happiness Hides）中。我们谈话后，索尼亚向我们介绍了哈里·里斯关于被理解感重要性的研究。谢谢索尼亚向我们介绍哈里工作。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必回看并查看我们整套的“人际关系 2.0”（Relationships 2.0）系列。如果你希望我们制作更多这样的系列节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。
Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you would like to help us build more shows like this, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次强调，如果你想帮助我们制作更多这样的节目，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。